Speaker 1: So I was not initially inclined
to talk about what's going on with Milo Yiannopoulos,
who is now saying he is no longer gay, he's
now heterosexual, I wasn't initially going
to talk about it, but it's getting enough
attention.
And I personally had an interaction with Milo
a couple of weeks ago.
And so I do want to talk a little bit about
it today.
Now, if you're not familiar with Milo Anapolis,
he's a right wing sort of provocateur who
for a long time got plenty of attention because
he was a gay conservative.
And he liked to say that because he's a gay
conservative, the left can't say all the things
about him that they would normally say about
heterosexual conservatives who are about so-called
family values and conservative beliefs and
on and on.
But ultimately, Milo fell out of favor with
the American right wing.
He supported Donald Trump.
You know, he did all the things that are the
right things that he should have been doing,
but he fell out of favor with them because
some videos came to light in which Milo expressed
views about sex with underage people.
That I won't repeat here, but the comments
were concerning even for people on the right
who previously supported Milo Monopolist.
So Milo sort of disappeared and there were
pieces written about him, about how he lost
his career and he lost his income and all
of these things.
And then Milo reappeared not long ago saying
he has left homosexuality and he has fixed
his life and has had quite literally a sort
of come to Jesus moment.
Now, the exact wording around this has to
be looked at closely.
I don't know if Milo is being consistent in
terms of is he is he no longer attracted to
men or does he simply choose to no longer
be romantically involved with men?
But he has the attractions with all of this
quiting homosexuality stuff.
These questions are always there and the answers
are rarely satisfactory.
I don't know.
And quite frankly, it doesn't matter because
that aspect of the gay thing I'm pretty sick
of.
But I'm going to play a clip where Milo showed
up on True News, not a program I'm familiar
with.
That's true.
True news.
And he said that as soon as he became X, gay
dogs stopped barking at him, which he believes
is a sign from God.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: When I made my announcement, the
first thing that happened, which will make
you laugh, but it's true.
His dog stopped barking at me.
I am one of those people, you know, everyone's
got that friend.
That dog's always go nuts around.
You familiar with this, right?
You got pets?
Yes.
Yeah.
But there's always somebody that dog.
Speaker 2: My dog doesn't bark.
Do I keep my dog it you.
But that's ok.
He like he
Speaker 3: said, people you must have some
work left to do bark.
That is true.
But but I was always one of those.
I had a sound so stupid.
But this is just how I think that God reveals
himself to us.
Right.
This is this is just my experience of it.
I was somebody who invariably, without exception,
always used to make dogs crazy.
So we have a friend who's a political candidate
down here.
Right.
And her campaign manager has two of these
little yappy dogs.
And they would not stop.
I couldn't be in her house in twenty minutes
because it would drive everybody crazy.
Even growing up, we had Alsatians, we have
black Labradors.
They just didn't like me at all.
But Dr. Barcott, many more.
And it happened almost overnight.
Now they seem to quite like me and it sounds
that's the stupidest thing in the world.
Speaker 1: So there's a lot there.
And I don't know if other people have noticed
this, but there's this thing where when you're
on a show like this, where I guess the hosts
are devout Christians or whatever, no matter
how one says God revealed himself to them,
no matter how stupid or bizarre, they always
accept it.
And they nod and they say, yeah, yeah.
Milo says, you know, this might sound stupid,
but I believe God revealed himself to me and
is sending me the message that I was right
to quit homosexuality by making dogs no longer
bark at me.
Oh, that's great.
That's, you know, God God reveals himself
to us in different ways.
Actually, that's idiotic.
That's absolutely ridiculous.
Why would God communicate in that way?
It makes no sense.
Oh, but God works in mysterious ways, like
through.
Dog barks Oh, OK.
Well then I guess that we can't touch that,
that it's it's an unassailable comment then.
Now my real comment, my real concern here
is two different things.
First of all, the damage that this ex gay
quitting homosexuality stuff can do to young
LGBT individuals who might see this or hear
about Milo quit being gay as if it's like
a hobby and thinking that that's something
they could do or something that they should
do.
Everything we know is that not living is one's
self is not a good thing emotionally.
And seeing this might plant the idea in other
people's minds that this is this is something
to be pursued or even to be applauded to to
what what Milo is doing when it's not.
The second concern is, remember, Milo was
pulled out of the public eye after being shamed
for his comments about sex with underage kids.
This entire thing, to me, seems like an attempt
to link homosexuality with pedophilia.
And that's why all these shows are having
Milo on to cheerlead what he's doing.
Because remember here, what's the framing?
The framing is Milo used to be gay and he
was gay when he said this stuff about sex
with underage kids.
Now he found God, now he's heterosexual.
And so now it helps to distance himself from
those things.
He said it's a pathetic attempt to link homosexuality
and pedophilia, which is another old homophobic
trope.
So I invited Milo to come on the show to talk
about all this.
I said you're welcome to come on.
I would love to speak with you about this
recent announcement.
And he wrote me back and he simply declined.
He said he's not interested in that.
And based on the shows I've seen him do lately,
it seems he's interested in the type of interview
he got on true news.
That's fine.
This is not me on a power trip saying how
dare he decline being on my program when we
are so much bigger than true news?
It's I understand why he said no to this show.
He would actually have to answer or at least
be asked.
He wouldn't have to answer.
It would be up to him.
He would actually be asked real questions
on this program.
And to me, this seems more than anything else,
an attempt to regain relevance and get attention.
Once and again.
The invitation to Milo remains open.
Welcome
on
the program.
Any time.